We would like to share some
information about our network.
When we start season two we see
the aftermath, the chaos.
There was such a cost to that
moment of complete honesty.
Alex!
-Just keep your phone on,
I'll call you.
In this season our characters
are searching for who they are
and trying to get through it in
a world
that's transitioning
very quickly.
The Morning Show is in a place
of real flux,
I mean Alex Levy
has left the show
and of course
the fallout from Mitch Kessler
having left the show
is still resonating.
UBA is a changed environment.
It's noticeably more diverse,
young, there are more women.
We are no longer running the
show from the perspective
of the white male patriarchy,
we have moved on.
Everything's different
this season.
(shouts)
In season two we meet Alex in a
very serene place.
I think she had to
get out of the chaos.
Please come back. You've
become a powerful voice
in the rebuilding and the
rebranding of a toxic empire
that… it's gonna rise.
There's a tremendous amount of
guilt that she's feeling,
her hypocrisy within herself.
She sort of became a feminist
hero and I think she has this
secret guilt that she isn't.
She has this history with Mitch
that she's ashamed of.
But something about her still
needs to feel relevant
and there's obviously still more
for her to excavate.
You know thing are gonna have to
be different
if we're gonna resume this,
quote-unquote, partnership.
I was the one exposing the
and I decided to include you.
Bradley steps into a
position where
she's trying to play the game,
she's trying to get ahead.
Bradley becomes the
number one lead anchor.
Whenever people think about
The Morning Show,
I want them to think of me.
And she thinks she's in control.
Laura Peterson comes up to
mentor Bradley Jackson.
I don't think they're using you
in the right way.
You're bigger than that.
When Bradley meets her
it's just hero worship,
there's just this
larger-than-life character.
The energy between Reese's
character and my character is
really interesting to watch
because you really see Reese's
character grow, just by
being in Laura's orbit.
I'm making a toast.
These two women, they changed
the course of human history
and we've got them.
The personal stake that Cory had
in season one was winning.
He didn't seem concerned about
the consequences.
You're a dead man.
-Said the corpse.
All of the sudden you're
watching Pinocchio become
a real boy and he has to
manage real feelings.
This is a battle for the
soul of the universe.
The show brings up so many
great talking points
about the world and
people being human.
People relate to shows
where human beings
ask the deeper question.
A show on a network allowed the
worst behavior to be
permissible.
Does that line up
with your experience?
I think some people are
ready to talk,
some people are not
ready for that.
It's okay to be anywhere you
want on that spectrum
but that's going to be tested.
There is a pattern of behavior
around here that disadvantages
the people of color.
We all develop a different
relationship with America
and I think that there are a lot
of people who are really
re-evaluating their place.
It's been brought to my
attention that for me
to use that term might be
considered insensitive.
So much of this show is showing
these real world relationships
unfold in real time and it just
allows the audience to
organically go on this journey
to answer some pretty
complicated questions.
You mean something Alex, you do.
As a leader, as a feminist, and
I want you to be these things.
What you thought was going to
happen at the beginning
of season two, all of a sudden
there's these detours
that you didn't think about
along the way.
We have more incredible
story lines,
much bigger and much
more impactful
than you could ever imagine
Camera two get the both of them,
two shot.
Onward and upward.
♪♪